[Music]
hello I'm Dave Rubin this is the Reuben
report it is June 8th 2023 you are not
watching the CNN clown Network you're
watching the totally independent Reuben
report very exciting
we are live streaming on Rumble YouTube
and locals today we'll be doing a
reubenreport.locals.com Community Q a
couple stories I want to hit up top uh
before we do it there's some interesting
what would you say there's a there's a
flavor in the air although if you're in
New York it's a it's a lot of burning
from uh from Canada have you seen the
story we're not even going to really
cover it today I'm not even going to
show you any images uh because we've got
a bunch of other stuff to get to but
it's really wild what is going on
apparently something like nine million
acres are on fire in Canada and now all
of this smoke and soot and the rest of
it is going down into America uh and New
York City yesterday was basically
looking like Mad Max Level air quality
and now this is going through
Pennsylvania and a bunch of other states
really crazy and of course they're
telling people to wear masks which in
this case might actually make some sense
it's really really crazy maybe at some
point we should grab an image of what's
going on in New York we could maybe
throw that in for the uh for the Q a in
just a little bit but we're going to
talk a bit about more of the yes because
it is
pride month
and as I tweeted out this morning let's
just be very clear on something there's
no such thing as the l g b t community
in that the t's would like to cut the
wangs off the G's and the boobs off the
L's this is a problem problematic as the
kids say but it is pride month thus the
trans thing has burst forth everywhere
and as I said to you guys last week if
your genitals you're still attached to
you congratulations all right before we
get to all of that stuff let's talk
about in oh we've got an image of uh
let's real quick I want to just hit one
other story on the Fly here so you know
we covered this the other day that Ron
DeSantis has sent 36 illegal immigrants
illegal immigrants uh to California now
California of course Gavin Newsom it is
a sanctuary State his cities are
Sanctuary cities nobody is illegal we
love diversity diversity is our strength
all this nonsense we showed you the
videos of these 36 people yesterday in a
car partying they're all young men they
all have nice clothes on sunglasses they
don't look like they're tired and poor
and the huddled masses that are supposed
to be coming here they look like people
who just want to get in on the party
that is America so Gavin Newsom is now
calling Ron DeSantis evil and you know
all the usual nonsense and then I
started thinking you know Gavin Newsom
he's got a lot of cash how much is he
worth he's worth about 20 million if I'm
not mistaken and you know he's somehow
related to Nancy Pelosi she's worth like
a hundred million somehow these people
Gavin Newsom who is the mayor of San
Francisco governor of California somehow
he made millions and millions and
millions of dollars
okay fine he has a massive Winery it's
called plump Jack Winery up there in
Sonoma and I was thinking maybe because
you know we sent these 36 people from
Florida we were a nation we're a state
we'll be a nation one day probably we're
a state of Law and Order so we don't
want them here we don't want illegal
immigrants here you're breaking the law
by definition in the first place but
you're going to Cali so look at this
this is Gavin newsom's Winery look at
that I mean he's got a lot of room up
there he's got a lot of nice tables
looks like people could even get work
pick in the grapes maybe I guess the
only downside to the Gavin Newsom Winery
is if you look at that party down there
looks like a lot of white people so it
might be some sort of white supremacist
Winery I don't know how am I supposed to
know uh but anyway maybe he will send
maybe he will offer a little bit of his
land and his Winery
to these 36 illegals oh we got a picture
just quick on the fly look what is going
on in New York tell me this is not
absolutely nuts do we have it look at
this this is yesterday in New York City
I'll talk a bit about more a bit more
about this uh when we get to the Q a
because I know there was a question or
two about it but uh speaking of air
pollution do I have the right sponsor
for today's show and it's a new one
Enviro cleanse guys if all home air
purifiers are the same then why did the
U.S Department of Defense select Enviro
cleanse to protect and purify the air on
board our Navy ships why is it used in
thousands of classrooms across the
country and probably should be used by
everyone in New York City right now well
here's a few reasons why Enviro cleanses
air purifiers have patented Earth
mineral technology at a hospital-grade
HEPA filter they also destroy cold and
flu viruses covid alert allergy
inflaming toxins mold and even more so
here's Enviro cleanse's promise to you
they guarantee you'll experience it's
far fewer colds and allergies coupled
with a better sleep at night don't
believe them they'll send you a free air
quality monitor to test the difference
in your home visit
[Music]
ekpure.com and use code Dave for 10 off
your Enviro cleanse home air
purification unit and a free air quality
monitor plus fast free shipping that's
150 in savings ekpure.com code Dave
ekpure.com code Dave and now back to me
okay so let's jump right into the woke
crazy story of the day on this pride
month
you know this Twitter account that I
like it's called n wokeness they put up
this image this is really interesting to
me uh Megan Fox you guys all know the
actress Megan Fox she was in
Transformers and can we it was any was
she in anything else besides a couple
Transformers she must have been in
something else
the roommate I don't know that one but
let's just say she's been its mother so
anyway she's she's a big Hollywood star
actually uh she has three sons that all
dress like girls I'm sure it's just a
coincidence now I don't want to make
this about these three kids so you don't
even really have to pay much attention
to looking at the kids or anything like
that uh Apparently one of the kids
according to Megan Fox identifies as
trans the other two are just dressing
like girls
foreign
book
you again you as an adult can dress
however you want and I guess you as a
parent can dress your child however you
want not I guess you can you can but is
something weird going on here in society
is there something bizarre happening in
society there is why is she going out of
her way first off it would be virtually
impossible like mathematically
impossible for one of her children to be
trans and the other two to be say
non-binary or or one of these other
phrases that now we all say it's sort of
like remember from a couple months back
that Disney executive when those videos
leaked those Zoom videos leaked from the
Disney meetings about the diversity
equity and inclusion thing and that one
woman said she's like I have a gay son
and a trans daughter and a non-binary
daughter and a two-spirit son and a and
it's like Lady it's just not even
possible that has far more to do with
you than your kids so what is it that
Megan Fox and I'm really not going after
the kids here I'm really not I'm not
even going after her I'm talking about
the idea broadly what is it that lends
itself so that an actress in Hollywood
wants to be out and about with their
trans son trans son and then the two
other Sons dressed as girls well we know
this thing is just rampaging through
Society right now in some ways it does
feel like it's getting so hysterical
that it might burn out but you know you
got to give the devil is doing these
things seem to just keep going and going
and going anyway yesterday
Ellen Page well you know her as Ellen
Page she is now known as Elliot page but
Ellen Page was a great actress Phoenix
just told me he had a big crush on her
when she was in Inception she was also
in X-Men she was really really great
cute pretty fun she was in a couple
other movies she was just a great
actress she now is known as Elliott page
and I and I believe has had all the
according surgeries uh she she he
whatever went on The View and listened
to the way Joy Behar frames what's going
on with the Trans issue right now
especially because it's pride month and
then well just take a look
[Applause]
it's not a surprise to you that
Republican lawmakers across the country
are continues to introduce hundreds of
anti-trans bills that will ban gender
affirming health care for transgender
youth
I'm not sure what age they're talking
about under 18 I think yes under 18.
right so uh why do you think the
transgender Community is being attacked
like this what is that about I mean it's
not like it's there 80 of the population
what's going on over there oh gosh
that's a big question I mean I think um
you know in many ways of course it's a
it's a political tool okay it's to to
gain votes it's to make people upset
it's to distract people from scare
people scare people real issues that are
happening in our society that do need to
be addressed
and
and I think in and there's such a such
an inundation of lies and misinformation
like when you had the amazing
representative Zoe Zephyr on recently
when she was describing what gender
affirming for affirming care for youth
actually okay it's not gender affirming
care for youth once again if you chop
somebody's gender uh genitals off that's
not affirming their gender it's doing uh
I would say quite the opposite uh it's
worth noting that Jordan Peterson was
suspended on Twitter what about a year
ago for saying that Ellen Page or Elliot
page is a biological girl I then was
suspended on Twitter for pointing out
that Jordan Peterson was suspended on
Twitter for it so that that's why this
thing it's not just about the specifics
of okay this person dresses this way or
anything else it leaks into the rest of
society related to free speech and Tech
and almost everything else that is going
on in current events and culture and all
the things that we talk about here all
the time also did you notice you can
rewind the video if you want to see
later co-worker can we throw it back to
it for one second just liter give me
like five seconds of throwing back to it
what's with the little pride logo they
have on there where the word pride looks
like it's a Halloween logo what what are
they what is that what is that what I
don't know why are they celebrating this
for a month okay it's just it's all you
get it you get it you get it uh but
Elliot page Ellen Page whatever is uh
has a book out and that's why he or she
is making the rounds right now and
townhall.com had an interesting op-ed on
what's going on uh with Elliot page and
diving into some of what's in the book I
thought it would be worth uh noting this
one particular point
it shouldn't come to this but if there's
one person to blame for casting doubt on
alleged hate crimes it's Jesse Smith I
should pause for a second we're going to
get to it in a moment but in the book
Elliott page claims that he was the
victim of a hate crime in West Hollywood
so that's what this is referencing here
the former Empire star destroyed his
career he after he hired two Nigerian
Brothers to Stage a fake racially
motivated assault on the actor the
script for the fake crime called for the
two brothers to hurl Auntie gay slurs
its malet a member of the LGBT community
pour bleach on him and then put a noose
around his neck with Paige the actor
recently released a memoir revealing
some Hollywood gossip and the Juno's
star Journey from coming out as a
lesbian and then transgender yet last
year the actor was verbally assaulted in
West Hollywood and subjected to
transphobic slurs now this is via the
New York Post actor Ellie page has
shared he was verbally attacked and
threatened by a crazed transphobic man
who shouted that he was the reason I
need a gun in Los Angeles last year page
36 was standing on a corner in West
Hollywood on his way to the Pink Dot
convenience store when the enraged and
hateful stranger approached him shouting
obscenities according to the New York
Times I'm going to effing gay bash you
the man yelled forcing the actor
to bolt towards the store in fear
employees at the pink dot escorted a
terrified page into the shop but the man
allegedly followed him and stood at the
store's doorway this is why I need a gun
the maniac reportedly yelled at Paige
through the glass door okay again a
quick Google search would reveal that
West Hollywood is an LGBT Bastion as
some on social media noted the story
happens to Tumble out when the book tour
is about to commence I'm going to effin
gay bashu is an oddly specific diatribe
Paige reportedly no longer feels safe in
Los Angeles with it which is eye roll
worthy if a liberal feels uncomfortable
in a city dominated by democrats
virtually since Kennedy was President no
place is safe is it a hoax maybe maybe
not but there have been too many too
good to be true stories on this front to
take things at face value anymore also
there appears to be a security camera at
pink dot where's the footage okay so
right so look
we all know the Jesse Smollett thing
turned out not only to be a hoax but a
hoax that was pushed by all of
mainstream media and all of our
politicians from AOC Bernie Sanders
Kamal Harris I'm sure some of them I'm
99 sure some of them still have their
tweets up uh for something that 100
turned out to be a hoax uh while they
were saying this is proof of how racist
America is and everything else Elliott
page where's the where's the video on
his or her phone anyone else that was
there the employees phones the security
camera from the place also West
Hollywood if you have not been there I
used to live in West Hollywood West
Hollywood is the gayest place on Earth
rainbow crosswalks there's almost no
straight people it's all gay people
everywhere and also the idea that you'd
be gabish I'm going to gay bash you
that's what he yelled I'm gonna gay bash
you it's so on the nose and although
during pride month I we're I'm in a gay
bash you would sound it sounds like a
party in some way anyway it all is just
ridiculous also it's worth noting that
Elliot page never reported the incident
to police so why am I bringing this all
up right like because obviously Megan
Fox what she does with her kids isn't
that important to you specifically how
Elliot or Ellen Page lives isn't that
important to you except that this
cultural thing then leaks through
everything right so then it ends up on
The View and then it ends up in schools
and then next thing you know you have to
hold up that flag which is not a flag
about equality but it is a flag with a
political message that is directly
counter to the American message so
that's why this stuff actually is
important so as we are talking about all
of this stuff we are seeing that woke
Hollywood which has been a dominant
corner of American culture is actually
collapsing on itself and I think that is
also uh part and parcel because pure
secularism secularism that is not
attached to anything beneath it
something Eternal and real and important
secularism on stair it simply does not
work and now this one is really you're
you're really going to find this one
interesting I was blown away when I saw
this I'm actually thrilled that I saw
this so Richard Dawkins Richard Dawkins
is one of the most influential uh
atheists in the world uh he's I think
he's in his probably early 70s at this
point I I've interviewed him about five
years ago at the 92nd Street Y in New
York City
um
he has been a profoundly impactful
thinker on the world anti-religion
pro-secularism but really pro-atheism
and he's been radical it's not just he's
been pro-atheism he's been radically
against religion
the woke have tried to destroy him many
times and suddenly in his 70s now he is
finally coming around to something that
I think many uh many of us see whether
we are devoutly religious or not uh take
a look at a portion of this interview he
did just a few days ago
the question is
is a
purely empirically practically in terms
of the success of our societies the
peace and prosperity of the world
is conventional religion
or what appears to be a successor which
are new slightly strange ideologies that
don't formally belong in the religious
category but as you say have religious
aspects which one was will be proven to
be more successful for the flourishing
of the species I guess we still don't
know but oh early signs are that this
new kind of religion which thinks it's
secular has some quite major problems
attached to it well if you care about
flourishing of the species yes but I
care about truth
you don't care about the flourishing
well I do care about it as a human being
but more more deeply I care about truth
so if your sense of Truth would lead to
the annihilation of these no I mean
would you be content I would not be
content of that and I would and but I'm
pretty sure it wouldn't it wouldn't
happen I mean I think I think that the
truth actually is a genuine value I mean
I I I
believe that uh a true scientific
outlook on the on the world would
actually be best for the flourishing of
humankind
okay now I get it he's a little muddled
there right because he thinks that
somehow flourishing of the species and
what he decided is truth which is that
there's no God that them somehow that
these things are at odds with each other
but it's a real concession by him maybe
it was a little bit by accident where
he's saying that religion if you care
about the flourishing of the species is
a net positive for society now again
he's still for whatever reason thinks
that that's at odds uh with being a
Believer even though everyone ends up
believing in something right like even
for the phase that I went through as an
atheist you end up believing in
something one way or another there's
something that is driving you whether
you sort of know it or not Jordan
Peterson and Sam Harris got into this
many times and Jordan would repeatedly
say sam you know you in essence you
believe in something you're laying out
what you believe to be true to me you
just don't believe that you believe in
it something to that effect right uh now
interestingly Jordan has had some
conversations over the years with
Richard Dawkins he saw that clip he
wrote something interesting here and
then I want to show you a clip from
Jordan he said I warned you Richard
Dawkins about what would happen in the
aftermath of the enforced death of
judeo-christian tradition you thought
people would become more rational and
that I was drunk on symbols so they had
talked this out and that's the line that
Dawkins used on Jordan that Jordan was
drunk on symbols because he was pushing
belief he was pushing the important
importance of these religious stories
now look I want to be very clear about
something I am not sitting here thumping
the Bible telling anyone they have to go
to church every Sunday or Temple every
Saturday or do this or that or whatever
it might be but it is becoming
increasingly obvious the more you are
completely disconnected from your
history and something related to belief
and something related to the
judeo-christian values that have set up
Western Society so we can all live these
incredible lives that we're living as
frustrating as they might be at times uh
you are going to end up one day wanting
to chop the genitals off kids you have
to worship something Beyond just
yourself and don't let me tell you that
how about one minute from Jordan
Peterson
do we need God to make sense of life um
your one minute answer begins now too
absolutely not that will do for an
answer okay do we need God to make sense
of Life Jordan well God is what you use
to make sense of your life by definition
this is one of the things I learned from
Young the highest value you have a
hierarchy of values you have to
otherwise you can't act or you're
painfully confused you have a hierarchy
of values whatever is at the top of that
hierarchy of values serves the function
of God for you now it may be a God that
you don't believe in or a God that you
can't name but it doesn't matter because
it's God for you and what you think
about God has very little impact on how
God is acting within you whatever God it
is that you happen to be let's say
following
I want to expand on that for just a
moment do you remember a clip that we
showed you about a year ago I think we
played it two or three times actually
where Jordan was on Tucker Carlson's fox
show when Tucker Carlson used to be on
Fox and they started talking about this
and Jordan said you know maybe it was on
the Fox Nation show I'm not sure
actually either it doesn't matter
um Jordan was uh Tucker was asking
Jordan about God and Jordan said that he
when he was in his early 20s decided to
believe in truth and that in and of
itself is a leap of faith like that if
you believe that truth in and of itself
is good there's probably no empirical
evidence for that right because you can
lie and cheat and steal and you can
attain a lot of things and you can amass
power and you might get away with it so
saying I am going to say the truth and
believe in the truth for the truth's
sake that is a leap of faith and he
connected that to his belief in God
that's really what he's saying there so
when you have this hierarchy of of ideas
that are important to you and if you put
Truth at the top
that is what sort of connects you to God
now what God is or anything else is not
uh well we're gonna do a whole bunch
more shows on this because I think it's
becoming increasingly important
um but I think you see the difference
between the line of thinking of Someone
Like Richard Dawkins who's saying oh
without religion Society probably won't
flourish but I really believe in Truth
where Jordan's connecting those two
things if you believe in truth
in essence that is believing in God and
then you can allow Society to flourish
so there you go on that let's get to a
little
reubenreport.locals.com Community Q a uh
we are doing this on the fly so if you
want to join the community right now we
can add a question or two uh feel free
to jump in Margot says hey Dave uh
seeing how New York is rapidly
deteriorating and the air quality is at
an all-time low isn't it time your folks
permanently move down here so my folks
are in the suburbs I've been trying to
get them to Florida uh you know they had
a place or they have a place sort of
have a place in Sanibel Island which was
decimated by the hurricane it's still
not able to be uh you know you can't
live in in the condo the island is still
a real mess I I've been there
I'm still trying to figure out some ways
that I can help as things come together
but they do spend some time here I've
been trying to get them down here I'll
tell you something funny yesterday
morning I was seeing all these pictures
and videos out of New York and I I
texted my parents I said how's how's the
weather in the suburbs like are you
getting it my mom said you know it
smells and it's kind of it's kind of
hazy whatever and I said Dad what's
going on he says I'm on the train going
to New York City he was going to visit
some old colleagues he retired a couple
years ago had the same job in New York
for about 30 years I mean that's like
like old school stuff he was going to
visit some old colleagues on literally
the day that the mayor of New York City
was saying do not be outside do not come
to the city I said dad you sure you want
to go you said he wanted to go they had
this set up and then I texted him at the
end of this day I said Dad how was it
how was the air quality blah blah blah
said it was a little overcast meanwhile
you look at the pictures and it's like
Mad Max out there so the guy's not a
complainer I guess is the uh is the
moral of the story uh but yes I would
love to I'd love to get my whole thing I
want everyone that I love and know and
care about to move to the free state of
Florida
James says is Gavin Newsom related to
Justin Trudeau if so can we get
California to secede from the U.S and
become a Canadian province or is the
California climate too warm to allow it
to be a part of Canada that is a good
question I don't know that they're
related but I think that they are
spiritually bonded by the devil
um I wouldn't have a problem with
California seceding I don't know that
Canada would want it and when Justin
Trudeau's reign of terror is over
hopefully Canada will sort sort of turn
itself around hopefully California will
turn itself around although I don't see
that coming anytime soon Kerry says did
you know that June 24th is international
fairy day
boy this gay pride month never ends
you see what I did there
Ferry as in like the Fairy Godmother or
the ferry from Pinocchio like that kind
of fairy or you know like oh my God
I did not know that I did not know that
and we will celebrate accordingly my
birthday is June 26th so maybe we can
combine International fairy day we could
have like a real three-day Bonanza the
24th International fairy day what can we
do on the 25th
uh
sorry we could have a celebration of
furries that's interesting that that's
what you said and then we could roll
that right into my birthday okay uh the
Eurasian says hi Dave do you think that
the original film The Matrix from 1999
would have been a total flop if it would
have come out today
interesting well I'm curious why you're
saying that it is such a spectacular
movie and I think still stands the the
test of time I watched it again maybe a
year ago I've seen it probably a dozen
times it's so great
um would they have told you that somehow
it was racist or any of that stuff sure
you know they did they ended up doing
four of those movies I guess I guess if
anything what you're saying is that
would it be mistaken as a documentary
and and that might be and then
documentaries just don't do as well as
major sci-fi Blockbusters that's
possible but you know they did the
original Matrix then they did uh Matrix
Reloaded then they did Matrix
um Revelations and then the last one
that they released like a year ago was
um
reloaded Revelations and then
Resurrection if I'm not mistaken uh the
last one was absolutely terrible like
like you guys were just in it for the
cash the other the second and third ones
weren't really incredible because they
told you everything that they could tell
you sort of out of the first Matrix uh
but you know I reference it all the time
because it's it's got such a good uh
explanation for in a Sci-Fi sense of
what is happening with our relation to
the digital world right and we talked
yesterday about this new Apple product
that's coming out where they're you know
they want you in augmented reality
strapping this thing and living in this
digital world and that's what Ready
Player one is all about and many other
sci-fi watch Black Mirror episodes are
all about
but with the Matrix basically was about
beyond the cool fighting and the
sunglasses and the love story and all
that was that humans will ultimately as
the digital world keeps expanding and
expanding which is happening all the
time humans ultimately as we live in
this world more will not only no not
know that we're living in that digital
world we will ultimately be the battery
that is all we will be we will be the
battery so that the digital world can
exist it's a little bit like the
machines in Terminator not needing us
anymore right Skynet is on and then what
does Skynet want to do it wants to get
rid of the people
I should write a sci-fi movie If I have
a little time put that in the calendar
would you uh Hey it says hey Dave I know
there are many more gays that feel as
you do that your cause has been hijacked
by the teas when do you believe they
start to speak out as you and others
have what will it take to bring about
that movement look I do think more and
more people are speaking up about it as
far as it being my cause like I
it's such an annoying thing it's like
you know
the justness of equality that everyone
should be treated equal under the law
and then you make decisions around your
life you decide what type of people you
want to live around and everything else
like that is the beauty of living in a
place like America that that is set up
to respect people's differences right
and we've done it so freaking well like
if we could just imagine if we just
could get a little plutonium and 1.21
gigawatts of power and a DeLorean and
you know if we could all just go back to
1995 where we had solved all of this
stuff right we imagine if we could do
that it would be so freaking beautiful I
actually think we can get to the other
side of it so it's partly why I've been
so outspoken about some of my political
feelings lately and candidates and
things of that nature
um but I think it's very important it is
actually very important for for whatever
there are literally millions of sane
gays and lesbians in the United States
people that are in your community that
are in your family that probably go to
your church synagogue we're local
community center that have kids that are
playing softball blah blah blah
you may not even know that some of them
are gay it doesn't even matter but that
just want to live in society like
everybody else and then came this
radical thing on the back of an equal
rights movement right it was an equal
rights movement let these people be in
the relationship they want to be in let
them live as everybody else lives as
opposed to living a life of endless
Hedonism if you don't let people be in a
you know long-lasting relationships and
build families and and attain or at
least hope to attain all of the things
that everyone else should want to attain
as a human being we're not going to let
you do that and then we wonder why these
people all act like crazy people so if
you if you eventually let them have that
and let people normalize it's great and
beautiful that's that's the promise of
equality right but then came this
radical anti-science anti-reality
movement and that is not to denigrate
the person the point zero zero zero
person out there who has gender
dysphoria who chooses to live a certain
way okay you get it
um but but the movement or the call does
whatever you want to call it has been
completely and utterly hijacked Anderson
Cooper should be speaking out about this
Don Lemon should be speaking out against
it Peter thielis but I'm just naming a
couple gay people Peter Thiel has spoken
out against that Douglas Murray has
spoken out against it Andy Cohen should
speak out against it it should cross
political divides
um
Chelsea Deborah says what do you do with
your empty bottles of tequila each one
is a work of art what a shame to just
toss them out I believe what you're
talking about are those beautiful Casa
Azul bottles that Reposado that I'm
always telling you guys about I am
working on my own tequila as I told you
we'll have a little bit more on that
hopefully I'm hoping we can get it out
maybe by uh by the Fall that might be
pushing it takes take some time and I
have to go down to Mexico which I'll
probably do in August where we can taste
some different things and really fiddle
with things and all that but those
beautiful decanters that class Azul
comes in and there's not only the that
that white and blue one is probably the
one you're referring to their Mezcal is
in a beautiful sort of black one with
really interesting texture to do it they
have a beautiful clear one for their
Plata which is basically Blanco they
have I mean they have bottles that I
don't have that are like ten thousand
dollar bottles that are absolutely
gorgeous they're all hand painted
I usually don't throw them out like if
you saw how many of those I have in my
garage I've probably got about 40 of
them in my garage I don't know what
we're going to do with them David is
constantly telling me can we get rid of
those things but they do seem beautiful
to me they could be used for something
so maybe I should melt them and create
something I don't know do we have a well
we need a Ceramics expert I guess can I
melt those we have to take that nice
little silver bell off the top we could
do something with those melt them and
create something I don't know Wanda says
can we get Spotify to stop littering my
Reuben report Spotify with covid-19 info
and warning banners uh it's on every
other episode do we have an image of
that we do have an image of that so
apparently I did not know this till this
morning until the guys told me about
this question and then Connor sent me
this image apparently in Spotify all the
time now they are warning you guys about
covid-19 I suppose I'm sort of an agent
of misinformation or something like that
I would recommend that you do what you
think is right and trust your own doctor
if you think he's pretty decent and talk
to your family about things that would
be called misinformation these days yeah
I mean these things are just they are
what they are we still get warnings on
Instagram posts we still get warnings on
YouTube and everything else it's why I
started locals it's why Rumble is
exploding right now uh people just don't
want this babysitting overreaching
nonsense from tech companies that don't
have their best interest in mind much
like the pharmaceutical companies that
don't have their best interest in mind
uh prosky says if Biden is truly running
for a second term wouldn't he have to be
put on a debate stage I'm not sure how
that works sorry for my ignorance no
it's not ignorance it's a good question
look the DNC the Democrat National
Committee
they set the rules right so so Joe Biden
as president of the United States is
head of the Democrat Party the the party
has rules like there's no there's no
outside
um organization that can tell the
Democrats what to do right the
Republicans have their set of rules the
Democrats have their set of rules now
the DNC is deeply deeply corrupt we know
that they cut deals with Hillary to get
rid of Bernie they really did that twice
to Bernie
um the Republicans you could say all the
things you want about the RNC I
mentioned this the other day but when
when Trump was going through in 2015 and
ransacking the entire party and running
through Rubio and Cruz and Rand Paul and
everybody else the party didn't do
anything to stop him from being on the
debate stage or try to cut any deals to
get rid of him or anything else they let
it let it be right they actually let it
be uh you know the RNC also doesn't have
super delegates so when the RNC when the
Republicans vote it's it's voted
proportionally you get the proportion of
the the amount of votes that you got and
then you're good to go right if you win
you win there's nothing they can do the
Democrats have super delegates so the
Democrat Party has a mechanism in place
so that if they don't like what the
people did they could actually override
what the people did in a primary with
super delegates so the entire DNC thing
is is deeply deeply corrupt
that was a long-winded answer of saying
they will never
never put Joe Biden on stage with RFK
right RFK is pulling at about 20 if
we're to believe the polls let's say
let's say they're roughly right that is
a significant number that is enough of
your own base to say let's have a
conversation about the future but
they're going out there and they're
sending the surrogates out there to say
we will not do that so they will not do
it and I'm telling you guys right now
I've said it before and I'll say it
again well first off I still don't think
Joe Biden is going to have a second uh
term I I just can't imagine him
surviving another year and a half I
don't mean I don't mean that he will not
be alive necessarily but just with the
with the level that he seems to be
breaking down and the falls and the
confusion and everything else but if and
and God willing Ron DeSantis is the
Republican nominee there is no way in
high held they will put Joe Biden on a
debate stage the the difference between
them will be so Stark and so drastic it
will be way too obvious having Trump on
there again Trump is way sharper blah
blah blah but they are roughly the same
age it keeps us all sort of within the
Overton window of this is what politics
is it's Trump or Biden it's not that
different it's not this massive
generational shift but if it's the
santis it will not be bidened they will
figure out a way to make it Gavin Newsom
or something to that effect because
they're not going to do Kamala either
like you just can't put
past these people what they will do to
maintain their grip on power Quinn says
Tucker on Twitter did not take down
Twitter the way desantis's announcement
on Twitter spaces did is Twitter looking
to expand their video footprint and his
Rumble locals looking to do any
collaborations
um okay so uh on the second part of that
um perhaps some you know perhaps let me
just leave it at that okay in terms of
what Rumble and locals and Twitter like
there's obviously a lot going on in the
video space and everything else so let
me just leave it at that on the first
part you know it's interesting so the
Twitter space And for those of you that
don't know what Twitter space is uh it's
the it's the audio portion of Twitter so
you can I could do it right now I could
start an audio basically like an old
school radio show people can join my
Twitter space and then I can welcome
them in and chat we're working on
features like that for rumble and locals
actually we acquired call-in uh just
about a month ago which is a company
that does just that it's something I've
wanted to do with this show all the time
I would love to be doing a live call and
show with you where instead of having to
talk to trolls all day who would be
calling in like if you're a subscriber
you get in we do it would be audio so
you don't have to show your face if you
don't want to and I just think it would
be a fun like all old school Larry King
asked when he used to take calls or even
old just more AM radio I just think it
would be a great feature anyway Twitter
spaces did crash the Twitter system when
DeSantis did the announcement and I you
know I was at Twitter that day and I was
talking to Elon after and he was
explaining it to a lot of people there
were a lot of technical reasons for it
they also have a whole bunch of problems
there because they're Engineers I Elon I
think still thinks or some of them are
working against him and everything else
the Twitter video
that uh that Tucker put up do we know
how many views it has now it's I think
it's around 100 million views something
like that which is insane right like
when's the last time something on
network television got 100 million views
but as I referenced yesterday the
question is what are they counting as a
view is it a view if Tucker puts up a
20-minute show and you just scroll past
it basically uh on your phone but you
see it for a split second is that a view
and you know you may go well who cares
what whether it's a view or not well
advertisers who want to put ads on these
shows they want it to be a view meaning
a legitimate view so for example when I
do ad reads on this show the advertisers
want to make sure that my views are
legitimate they don't want somebody to
be like oh Dave got a million views on
this but they only watch the first six
seconds of it and the ad read wasn't
until three minutes in right that's
usually by the way this little Insider
stuff why when whenever you watch
whatever show you watch whether you
watch this show or virtually any other
podcast YouTube Rumble type thing it's
why there's usually add reads more to
the front of the show because they know
people have limited attention spans one
of the things I'm very very proud of is
our retention rate on this channel is
unbelievable like I've discussed it even
with our our YouTube contact like you
guys actually watch like often 80 to 90
percent of this show and a good portion
of you watch the entire way through
YouTube has very low watch times our
watch times
are exceptionally good like we're in the
top I think it's like 97 percent of
watch times which is really really
awesome and I I think a credit probably
to what we're doing here
um anyway there's a lot to talk about on
the on the tech side with that they'll
have to announce like what are these
views did you know if Tucker puts up a
20-minute video did 100 million people
actually watch it or was it two million
people that watched it and 98 million
people that scanned past it et cetera et
cetera so some of that will shake out
but look there's a lot to really answer
your question in terms of Rumble and
locals and Twitter and everything else
there's a lot going on in this space and
it's good by the way one other thing on
the Tucker front if you did not see this
fox subsequently after Tucker put the
show on Twitter they are now suing him
claiming he's not allowed to do that
contractually until his contract ends in
25. he's saying that's a violation of
his free speech from what I saw in the
article in axios about it I mean it it
does sound like Fox unfortunately has a
good handle on what's going on here that
he contractually is just not allowed to
put things on video sites or sites where
his voice would be expanded in that way
I don't know that it's a First Amendment
right right like he can say whatever he
wants privately but he does have it in
his contract that he wasn't allowed to
be on these certain websites it's shitty
but it's it's been business it kind of
is what it is but we'll see maybe he'll
just keep doing it and fighting them and
we'll see Lloyd says will you expand
your staff to have a California
dedicated reporter
Connor You're Going Back to Cali
I don't think I can send someone to Cali
at good conscience you know what I mean
like how could I do that
Phoenix you're from L.A could I send you
back there Phoenix can't even go back
there nobody wants to go back I can't do
that I can't do that
um we are figuring out some ways to
expand though and I think we'll have
more on that in the fall a couple things
will be changing around probably
September time we're going to figure out
some new ways to to do some things I'm
working on some stuff so stay tuned but
I don't think a California Outpost uh
will be one well I guess maybe we could
just hand a camera we could maybe strap
a camera to one of those zombie homeless
people like one of those fentanyl people
what if we strap the camera to their
head and they're like out there all day
and then like people it could be a
24-hour camera you know what I'm talking
about like these endless live streams
they're out there it'd be kind of
interesting you know any smoking crack
and then you know
snow baby says uh would you have to pay
them how would that even work
we pay an infantile I guess all right
figure out where we can get some well I
know we can get fentanyl in San
Francisco all right it's all working
itself out hang tight snow baby says now
that you two have experience being
parents and tried some different things
what is a product or item you found
invaluable uh with your boys what is
something you feel like hasn't been as
helpful or necessary or or utterly
disliked well I'll tell you very easily
the thing that I dislike more than those
I cannot have electronic beeping sounds
in this house you know you get a lot of
gifts and God bless everybody and thank
you everybody who got us gifts very
happy the boys are very happy it's great
both of them by the way are like 95th
percentile in height and weight they're
huge like they're taking over I I know
I'm I'm on my way out over here I I've
lost the war
my days are numbered
um but you know the electronic things
where you press this button and beep
beep beep beep and ding ding ding ding I
can't deal with any of that so we have a
lot of wooden toys uh we have you know
there's some metal metal keychain I can
deal with a little metal clanging I
cannot have beeping and whirring and
buzzing and also lights I can't have red
light blue light green light I can't I
just can't do it I can't do it I never
liked Simon remember that game Simon uh
growing up I cannot be around buzzing
and dinging and all of that stuff which
is ironic because I like Sci-Fi movies
but I just can't have it so we have a
lot of wooden toys rubber plastic that
kind of stuff
um so that's uh that
um what has been something that's been
really good
um well the funny thing is I mean I
guess all parents now know this you buy
all this stuff for your kids or you get
all this stuff and then the kids only
want to play with the stuff they're not
supposed to play with so literally like
they want to play with a coffee mug
Justin actually the other day it was bad
it was on Saturday morning I was having
an ice car coffee in the morning but it
was in a mug like this and I'm sitting
on the couch and I'm feeding him and his
hand just whacked the mug and the Coffee
iced coffee all over him he got a little
coffee in his mouth I thought he was
gonna like wig out all day he was
actually totally fine and he barely
cried he never cries he's smiling
constantly
um but they always want everything that
they're not supposed to have so like if
you have a pen they want a pen if you
have your keys they want your keys
they're obsessed with the phone
um but one thing that's been really
great my parents got them
um you know I don't even know what you
call it it's just like one of these
units that you can just kind of put them
in and there's a bunch of things that
they can push back and forth and put
their finger in and pull and push and
all that and that has been very good for
just like those moments where I just
like can't chase him he's always trying
Justin especially
just anywhere that you're not supposed
to be if I open up the fridge he bolts
to the fridge like
kids kids what are you gonna do uh Robin
says will you be interviewing vivec and
any updates on who might host the
debates I suggest Tim Poole well the
debates are going to be hosted by
Network people I mean the debates are
network debates so it's going to
unfortunately be mostly partisan
Democrats even for the Republican
debates however uh Rumble is the
exclusive live streamer of the
Republican debate so I will be at all of
the Republican debates including August
23rd for the first one in Milwaukee
that's the day I'll come back on the
grid so it's an abbreviated Off the Grid
August for me this year
um and we will figure out ways maybe we
can get Tim Poole there some of the
other Rumble creators and we could do
post game things as for vivec you know I
got into a little Twitter spat with
vivec over the last couple days he kept
repeatedly going after DeSantis in a way
that I thought was unfair claiming that
he's signing hate speech laws I made it
very clear and I tweeted the the text of
this law it's a property rights law we
got into a little bit I offered to do a
Twitter spaces with him uh last night
they came back and said he'll do your
show today except I'm doing this show
right now and I wanted it not just to be
heard by my audience I wanted it to be
heard by everybody meaning if he tweets
it out and I tweet it out
um
anyway it is is what it is but I'll be
happy to sit down with any of the
candidates once again and and again I
think I think the only way I can do this
and it gets the more I share my opinions
I suppose to a degree it gets harder to
interview people because then they sit
down with me and they know my opinions
but you know even when I sat down with
Nikki Haley about a month and a half ago
um Nikki knows that obviously I support
DeSantis I love what's going on here in
Florida my life has been enriched by all
this and everything else and I treated
her exactly the same way as I would
treat any other guest it does get more
complex like as this thing Burns hotter
and as we get closer to the election it
might get a little bit more complex to
do that as a matter of fact I think it
for sure will but I'll just I'll just do
my best but at least I'm telling you
what I think right as opposed to when a
candidate Republican or Democrat goes on
CNN and the and the host pretends that
they have no opinions it's so odd that
these hosts Jake Tapper the rest of them
they do politics for a living all they
ever talk about is politics but if you
ask them their opinion on anything they
never tell you so I think the best I can
do is be honest about my opinions and
then let the chips fall where they
Mitchell says have you used your Big
Green Egg as a smoker yet what's your
favorite uh to grill Smoke on the egg
any tips I love that big green egg I
will I will definitely do something in
it we did some ribs on it uh this past
weekend I'll I'll do some posts and
locals this weekend
um you know a brisket if you really do a
brisket right the biggest brisket I did
in there was like 18 pounds or something
like pretty massive it was when I have
my whole family here when the kids were
born
and I went overnight I think we did it
for like 13 14 hours you got to get up a
couple times a night you got to Spritz
it you gotta wrap it put it in a blanket
like it's a whole bunch of stuff make
sure the seasoning is just right I love
that big green egg it's such a great way
to cook you smell like smoke after I
love you they call it caveman the
caveman way of searing so normally you
know when you're cooking in a smoker
you're using indirect heat right because
you want it to cook via the smoke so
what you do is you know you have
charcoal you've got flame and then you
put a plate basically it's like a
ceramic plate so the flame hits the
plate and then it Cooks via the smoke
but then at the end if you're cooking a
great piece of meat whether it's a
brisket or whether it's a rib eye or
whatever it might be you want to get
that awesome sear right you want a
little Char on it you want that that
flavor that that that you want some
burned ends so what you do is normally
what you would do is you'd remove the
plate and then you would just cook it on
the grate so the flame would just go up
on it like that right and you'd do maybe
I don't know two minutes on each side
the caveman way of doing it which is
what what I love is that you take the
grate out now you get that flame
freaking going right bonfire from hell
right and then you just take the piece
of meat and you throw it right on top of
the coals and it chars and it's
crackling and it's Smoky I've done that
many times when when I've had the guys
over for uh for birthdays and things I
love doing it that way
um some people don't because it's a
little more then you got to put on
special gloves to get your hands in
there you don't want to burn everything
down but I freaking love that thing uh
Daniel or Danielle says what is
something that you didn't realize was
terrible in California until you were in
Florida and it was gone
well like there there's all the obvious
stuff at the time which was all covid
related and everything else but yeah I
say this all the time maybe you guys can
come up with one too but like it really
is it was just the spirit of life that
was depressing me there without really
realizing it everything that we did in
my house even throughout covid
we eat well you know we have decent
means obviously we had good friends we
had families come visit we were running
you know like it was the freak in 1920s
prohibition we were running secret
illegal parties like we never stopped we
just never stopped I was grilling every
night we were I was doing my show from
home you know I was lucky also because
because I had already done the home
studio everyone does the home studio now
I was basically the first guy in at a
real level of the home studio thing so
right when covet happened when everybody
was just doing Zoom things on Fox and it
looked like crapper on CNN or whatever
you know I I think that actually ended
up helping my career a lot that that
six-month period at the beginning of
covid because my studio looked awesome
it was awesome it was a grade A
television quality studio so shows were
more inclined to have me on because it
looked right hopefully it had a little
something to do with what I was saying
but like that that truly was part of it
to some extent
um so it was all good like what was
going on in our life we
you know we listen to good music like it
was now I think in some ways it was like
the good old days my life's very
different now we have kids it's
beautiful in a new way but like it is
different than than it was
um but it was the General like
depression of everybody there in fear of
everybody over there I always tell you
the thing about like just walking my dog
and people pulling their dogs the other
way and then and then literally I think
it was uh I know the day that I said I
was going to sell my house was September
I think 14th 2021 because it was three
or four days after the recall had failed
I got audited by the state of California
and then I was done I mean I was sort of
mentally done anyway but that was the
day I literally called my real estate
agent I said sell the house I just I'm
getting out of here I literally
basically said to her I'll sell it for
what I bought it for I just have to get
out of here
um
but there was a day a little bit before
that where David and I went to the
supermarket together and this was at the
point where it became we were past the
point where it made sense to wear masks
but they didn't stop with the mask
mandates and everything David didn't
like masks either but he would put it on
to go in so my policy was you know what
I'm not going to put it on to go into a
supermarket or anywhere else but if
someone asks me I will put it on so we
would walk into the store we went into
Pavilions on Ventura Avenue I'll never
forget it security guy there I walk in
sir put on your mask okay I put on my
mask I put it beneath my nose but I did
put it on we were walking picking up
some groceries another security guy
walking around the store sir your mask
has to be above your nose like this so I
put it above my nose then and this was
like this was like the moment we're
getting eggs we're standing in front of
all of the eggs and now I have my mask
below my nose again another security
guard so a third security guard sir you
have to put your mask above your nose
put my basketball my nose and David
turned to me and he said
you know we don't have to go food
shopping together anymore
and that was like when I was done like
done done because I was just like this
is so insane like he didn't mean that
out of anger to me
but it was like he just wanted to go to
a supermarket in peace and not be
harassed and he he actually respected he
would always be like you know I respect
what you're doing it's a little Annoying
to be harassed when we're at the stores
um and somehow sometimes he would
actually do it too but like
that sort of thing
um which definitely did not it's not to
say it never happened in Florida but
that sort of thing that overreaching
control it's it's such a part of
everything that now you see that I fight
against that I once I live here so that
would be my answer to that uh we have a
post game show if you want to get a
couple more questions in or if you want
to join us at reubenreport.locals.com
right now we leave you with evil
communist Justin Trudeau and uh we've
got a Friday panel Extravaganza for you
tomorrow who's on tomorrow
Liz wheeler and Amela epinobi will be on
the show tomorrow that's a good one we
haven't had them on for a while uh see
everybody else tomorrow post game in
just a sec
I will never apologize for standing up
for an lgdp L GT LBG
lgbtq 2 plus uh kids rights
foreign
[Music]